I've always thought that I was a fan of some of the bands that I've mentioned.
And I've joined, like, band fan websites for, like, REM and even, like, Delamitri, these small, more obscure bands.
And I'm not a fan compared to those people.
Like, I don't know a single, you know, REM band member's middle name.
And so therefore I don't count it.
Like that's the beginning of the process of like they know which classes they took, which which professors at UGA.
Like, I'm like, man.
Well, that's weird.
I'm not a fan.
I mean, they are standing.
The differentiation is that they're standing.
That's the that's the new term.
So they're a super fan.
You know, that's that's like that's another level.
I mean, you got to be you have to have so much time on your hands on the Internet all fucking day to be that level of like into somebody.
You know, that would be embarrassing to me.
Well, I feel but it's I think of it differently.
I think it's like everybody's a scholar.
They just have different things that they're interested in.
Right.
Like effectively what they're doing with, say, REM is what I do with Nietzsche.
Like, so you're not but you're not like trying to figure out what kind of, you know, mustache oil like Nietzsche.
That's right.
I mean, there's the fetishizing.
Yeah, that's the analogy.
You're not drawing paintings of Nietzsche and have them all over your wall and shit.
I mean, you're not like writing books about him, though.
You're responding to you're responding to his thinking.
Right.
But actively making Nietzsche not Nietzsche rather than trying to find, you know, little like paraphernalia.
It's also your job.
Yeah.
Well, but I'm just fortunate that there is a recognizable industry where I can get paid to be like a Nietzsche to lose.
They're not fan, you know, as opposed to not they're not existing something where one can be a, you know, a childish Gambino fan and be paid for being that, you know.
Right.
Yeah.
But I would again, I would say this is going to be to try to draw us into the to lose is that like the the work of representing, you know, REM or or Nietzsche is not the work of thinking in response to the music.
Or to the writing that like the goal to try to hypostasize all of the little elements, all of the little atoms of, you know, this or that person, even you try to use it to as an explanatory force.
It's like, ah, they took this class at UGA with this professor at this time.
And that explains this lyric as a as the goal of which is to like to fix, you know, that thing.
Right.
It's it's.
Yeah.
Well, it's hermeneutic and hermetic at the same time that like try to, you know, encapsulate, you know, this this this this figure to put them on display all laid out, you know, to use that Derridian line.
It is true. But I would say the analogy, maybe the more accurate analogy rather than me and the work that I do is like I know plenty of people who are, you know, Faulkner scholars or Fitzgerald scholars who are exactly that.
Right. Like that that what they're doing is, you know, really not that different than being a fan at this at this kind of level.
You know, and it's just that it's because it's books rather than popular music, that they have a profession and that they are, you know, they get paid to teach other people their fascination with childish Gambino.
Right.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, that's why most, like, literature scholars go into grad school and get their Ph.D. because they're a fan of a couple people.
Right.
You know, and they want to keep reading.
They don't necessarily want to write about it.
They have to.
You know, they just want to read those people.
That's true.
The writing of it is, I mean, this is what I'm trying to get at, is the writing of it can be, I think, paralyzing for that style of orientation.
I mean, if you think of writing as something more than just recording, right, if you're just, like, going to record a series of facts that you've uncovered about somebody, then then sure.
But like if the goal was to activate the Faulkner or whoever else it is, then the more you do that, the less sure you become of this Faulkner character and the stability of the Faulkner character.
And the more you kill the possibility of being a fan in that from that perspective.
So like that paralysis is self-preserving in some ways in order to maintain this relationship to this thing that I fetishized.
I can't give it too much room for movement.
I have to keep it in the display case.
I can't, you know, I have to keep it in mint condition.
And they do have lots of, I mean, are you guys on fan sites?
Like, cause they do have constant sort of debates about what's the worst song on Automatic for the People or what's the, you know, things that I'm just like, I just don't have any interest in the conversations at all.
Every once in a while, there'll be a neat little anecdote related to one of the making of the album.
That's something that some, one of them said in an interview or something, but like for the, for the most part, and I just kind of scan it at this stage.
But I was, I've just been kind of blown away and maybe it's just my naivete.
Like I, I just was not a part of fan communities for anything.
And then becoming part in the last year of these various fan communities and just being like, wow, they all operate the same way with different targets, obviously.
But like they all are just sort of totally obsessive about minutia related to anything having to do with these five guys or four guys or whoever it was in, in the band.
Like, um, and making of the albums and the tours and the shows and the set lists.
And the, I mean, you know, the, the instrumentation and, you know, it's just like, wow, man, I'm not a, compared to you guys.
Like I can't call myself a fan of any of these bands because I, I couldn't even tell you all of their album names.
Like that's just not that important to me.
Yeah.
Well, it seems like it's about joining a community for those people too.
Cause if they're posting on those forums like daily or weekly, I mean, it's just.
You can tell they have ongoing conversations.
Yeah.
And that's not a bad thing.
I mean, those people, they need that outlet for me though.
Like being a fan of something is a little bit embarrassing.
Like it should be too.
Like I am a, I am a fan of Future, for example, is like my favorite rapper.
But to me, there should be a little bit of shame around that.
Like, I can't just be advertising constantly.
Like I'm the fucking Future super fan, man.
I'm going to go to all his shows.
I love this guy.
Like it, it is embarrassing.
Why is it embarrassing?
Cause I agree with you, but I, I mean, I, I'm totally sympathetic to that, but what is
the source of the belief that it should be embarrassing or shameful to be that invested
in another, in an artist?
I mean, there's levels to it.
I mean, first of all, maybe this is the wrong way to look at it, but that you're, he's a
guy.
So you're a, you're subordinating yourself to another man and like basically bowing down
to another dude.
So it's a gender thing.
The beta status.
We need to find you another gender bending.
I don't know how gender bending future is, but I mean, he's saying it, he sings, you know,
any rapper who sings and, and that's a vulnerable, it's right.
It's way more vulnerable than Tupac's sort of staccato, you know, gangster rap, you know?
So even just the act of singing for a black guy, I think is, is, is at least a little
bit, um, gender fluid.
Um, maybe at this point it's too convoluted, but, and then the other thing is just like,
it's like wearing somebody's like Jersey, like with their name on your back.
Like, what are you doing?
You know, that's a, you know, that's a, you're a grown man wearing another man's last name
on your back.
I agree with you, but people do it all the time.
Like lots of people.
Yeah.
I know.
I don't have a single Jersey and never have like, uh, there needs to be more shame, not
less shame, more shame in the culture.
That would be my thesis.
So I, this is fascinating to me because I would, you know, I, I've, I would call myself,
I mean, like, again, you know, given the kinds of, of, of definitions we've been using for
fan, I'm not a fan of anything.
Right.
Like I like things, you know, I watch things, I'll read about things.
I'll even get into the minutia of things, but that minutia always then like launches
me over to something completely unrelated.
Right.
Like I can't sustain an interest in the minutia for the sake of the minutia.
Cause it always, if it's interesting to me, it's because it propels me somewhere sort
of like in left field.
Um, right.
But you know, I, I've, I've liked watching the Pacers for years.
I've liked listening to Pink Floyd for years.
I read about them.
I watch a lot of the games.
I have never had the desire to walk around wearing a Pink Floyd t-shirt or to have a,
you know, like Reggie Miller is probably my favorite, you know, basketball player of all
time.
I would never, ever own a Reggie Miller jersey.
I'm totally getting you one.
Yeah, yeah.
We're both going to buy you one.
Yeah.
I mean, I would probably want you to like, but like, I mean, but it is interesting.
The, the, the, the gendered, uh, dynamic in, in there, I don't think I've, this is probably
maybe just cause I have not, um, reflected on it enough.
I don't think it has ever anything to do with it being another man.
Uh, you know, I don't think that I would, I couldn't imagine doing it with a woman like
either.
No, I love Brittany Howard, but I don't think I'd walk around in an Alabama Shakes t-shirt
I love Nina Simone.
I'm definitely not wearing a Strange Fruit t-shirt for a lot of reasons.
But, um, yeah, yeah, it's, it is, it is, I mean, maybe just, I think submission is a sort
of, but not, but a submission that is inactive, like a submission that is like a conflation
form of submission.
Cause I'm, I'm the one on the podcast that's always thinking like, Hey, a certain kind of
vulnerability or a certain kind of subordination to this sort of thing is really interesting.
But only in so far as it activates a sort of mutually transforming line of flight.
But I think what I don't like about the jersey and, you know, the t-shirt and the fan culture
and especially the super fan culture is that it's a subordination without transformation.
That it is like a, it is, it is pure subordination.
Right.
Yeah.
And mimetic.
Like it aims to simply reproduce the thing.
Yeah.
Like all those Twitter accounts.
Right.
Yeah.
I think that's a big part of it.
Like you want to be that person.
Yeah.
Which is totally different by the way.
For example, like if I try to imitate, you know, on the basketball court, if I were ever
a shooting guard, but if I were trying to imitate the way that Reggie Miller runs off screens,
or if I were trying, if I were the musician and trying to imitate the way that, you know,
Jimi Hendrix deals with, with bar chords or something like that, that's a totally different
kind of mimesis.
Right.
Because I would, it would fling me off in different directions because I don't have
Reggie Miller's, you know, body and I don't have Jimi Hendrix fingers or whatever.
And I mean, that's how you have to start in a lot of, with sports and with a lot of creative
processes.
Like you kind of have to start by copying people just to get the, like the techniques down.
You know, you can't just, you're not going to become Michael Jordan without watching
Michael Jordan or like, you know, reproducing some of his moves.
You're not going to become Jimi Hendrix or some version, a great guitarist without studying
and reproducing at some level, at least in practice sessions, some of those riffs.
Right.
But the question, the question is the telos of that reproductive or mimetic that it's, it's,
is it to, you know, be Jimi Hendrix or is it to acquire components of what it means to
be Hendrix?
Right.
So, so I get that.
I mean, I, you know, for instance, like I don't even, when we're thinking of the t-shirt
thing, I've never even been comfortable wearing clothes with logos on them.
Like, I just don't like that.
And so now to a certain extent these days, you sort of have to, like, it's kind of hard
to even find something that doesn't have an Adidas or Under Armour or something, you
know?
So, and that seems less, or I've just gotten more, more accustomed to it, but I think it's
exact, I mean, it is, it's this weird way.
I mean, I would say it's kind of individualism, right?
Like, I just don't want to be associated with that team, you know, like I, because, because
being a member of a team seems to be such a distinct person, you know, a codifying personality
trait.
And I want to like, I can't be contained by any corporate logo, you know, I mean, I think
I definitely have that.
And it is, it's an adolescent resistance to codification.
Um, but yeah, I have the same feeling, but my response is to wear like single color, you
know, nothing on the, you know, Henley shirts, which is definitely not like individuating
me, right.
It's making me more like, you know, more of an anomaly or not an anomaly.
At least, at least not corporate though.
Yeah.
You're, you're anonymous, but you're also not corporate.
You're not explicitly corporate.
I, the banana republic is trying to leave, right?
Right, right, right.
Yeah.
I mean, my, my approach to that, cause I wear a lot of like tall tees, which is something
I've just started, like, so like big boxy t-shirts that like don't really show, like,
you know, they're not tight at all, but most of them, you're not going to find ones that
are just plain, or I'm not going to wear like a, a white tall tee, like a early 2000s
rapper or like Allen Iverson.
I'm not doing that, but what, so instead of wearing like the Nike tall tee or like the
Supreme, which is the big streetwear brand now, Supreme makes all that bullshit streetwear
that every 14 year old white kid wears.
So like, instead of that, I'll find a brand that nobody's heard of and their logo is unidentifiable.
And so it just looks like I want it to be something unrecognizable.
So I'll still wear something that's clearly branded.
They'll have the logo right here on like where the pocket would be, but it's like Brixton,
you know, Brixton is the brand that's one of the t-shirt companies I like and nobody wears
that.
So it's like, well, okay, at least this is something else, you know, you know, I mean,
but we seem to be hitting on is the impossibility of non-individuation because I mean, like,
let's be clear wearing the, I mean, like, think about how you get individuated in terms of
a certain kind of exoticness or like, you're so hip, you know, the brand that clearly I don't
know about and the sheer unrecognizability of it is a recognizability, right?
Yeah.
It's a vicious circle.
You can't get out of that, that corporate impulse.
I don't think that there's a, you know, an exit button, even if some of them, you know,
feel better.
No, no, yeah.
But there really did used to be when I was a kid that people would have their guest t-shirts,
right?
Or whatever the jean, the designer jean brand version was.
And I mean, there's a very particular part to that too, because I just never really quite
understood why I would be advertising, like why I would pay to advertise, like if they want
to give me free shit, you know, to wear and advertise their thing, I think I would feel
differently about it.
But the idea that I would pay and frankly pay more for this $20 t-shirt instead of a $10,
like, you know, this, pay for a $20 t-shirt to advertise their guest's jeans.
They should be paying you.
Right.
I just, I guess I never really, I never understood it, but I do think that the kernel for me is
hidden in this like desire for individuality.
Again, despite the fact that I recognize, you know, it's impossible.
So you're, yeah, you're just assuming the individual posture of, you know, resistance
to individual, like corporate individualism, but it's still, I mean, I get that.
I just way more comfortable without brand names on my shit.
So the thing I'm impressed by is we've successfully done an hour of this and there's literally nothing
we can keep, right?
Like, I'm, I'm going to edit this one.
I, I volunteered to edit this one.
I can get us under, I can get us under an hour real easy.
Yeah, I got to be, I got to be honest with you.
Honestly, Nathaniel, your way of thinking about this is way more interesting than mine.
Like it just is.
So I got to, I have to acclimate to your way of thinking about this.
Like I am, I am thinking of it too much in terms of a product container model.
Um, and, and, and I am, and I hear when I hear you guys talk about it, it's like what
you guys are experiencing and re-listening to this is way more interesting than what I'm
hearing and re-listening to this.
So I, I've got to, I got to learn that.
I mean, that's that fucking, I mean, it's that simple, it's that simple, right?
It is.
Well, it's also like, what do we, we never wanted this to be a lecture format, you know?
That's right.
So, and to me, we've already kind of covered this, but the loose conversation, even when
it's centered around dense theory, it to me is much more appealing just from the listening
perspective than like The Philosophy Now or whatever podcast where he just goes through
a summary of all their stuff.
It's like, you're, you're, you're over, you're, I think you're overestimating a little
bit how much people want like stability and consistency.
And I am sort of thinking of like, I guess I'm thinking of a target audience that is much
more of an intro, you know, like people who don't really know anything about it.
Whereas I think the target audience for the type of listening that you're talking about
are people that are already sort of immersed in the theory thing, you know?
And so I'm like, I want to give them some training wheels and you guys are like, fuck
the training wheels.
We're not doing, that's not what we're doing.
And you're right.
I mean, that's why I said like, I need to learn, I need to relearn like, or to learn when thinking
about it at the podcast level, what it is, because that's how I treat it when we're interacting.
I just don't treat it when I think about making a podcast.
So that's where, honestly, which is why you guys should be the lead in organizing how we
do the podcast.
Because I, my tendency is to sort of make it this top-down instructional, even, even though
it's conversational, it's still organized around an instructional telos, you know?
I've really kind of committed to writing lectures for a lot of my undergrad classes for like,
I hate it when a whole class is dominated by a lecture, but I also discovered that I needed
a little bit of something, you know, even if it's like half the class or a quarter of the
class.
And I've really enjoyed writing them, but I've discovered that the lectures that I'm
the most proud of are the thing that the ones that I think where I've just done a really good
job of sort of like introducing and encapsulating and making a point, you know, a smart point in an
accessible way.
And by the way, the ones that my students feel like I've done the best job on as well, like
it kills conversation.
We're so like, well, dude, you just made a really smart point about I followed everything.
It was, it was, you know, I enjoyed, I feel like I learned something and that's great.
I've got nothing to say about it now.
And, you know, I, I think, I think about the other podcasts that I listened to that are
really nicely, neatly packaged like that, like, um, the, um, History of the English Language
podcast, it rarely prompts me to think it's really good.
It's like, I learn a lot, but it's very unidirectional.
And I really do think that treating this as an invitation, I mean, that's like, I mean,
if we feel invited to, to think along with us when we've already done the thing, no, I
mean, the rest of the world would say that's super narcissistic of us, but I don't think
that's narcissistic if you believe in the stability of the ego, but otherwise to me, like, I don't
find that narcissistic when it's like, when I feel like I am prompted to think when I listened
to that episode number four and we were doing this thing on the universal picture, I was
like, Oh, that's an interesting point that I hadn't really thought of before.
I don't find that narcissistic.
I just find that to be learning.
Like, yeah.
Well, I also find it to be like, yeah.
A destabilization of the ego.
Right.
That's like, it's not really me.
Yeah.
I mean, I was the one who said the interesting thing earlier in the general, and I was like,
that was my voice, but yeah.
Yeah.
Well, you wouldn't call rereading your own writing narcissistic.
Although I guess if you did it compulsively, it'd be a little strange.
Like, just like, like if you already had your book and you're just reading it every day,
like John's got the future of invention.
Definitely a Borges character.
Like the author who writes his novel and does nothing but rereads it for his entire life.
Totally a Borges character, of course.
That kind of brings us back to the fan versus trying to reactivate it.
Like, I mean, there are two ways of rereading your stuff.
It's like to sort of stew in your own glory or steep in your own glory.
And then there's the other ones that like to undo it and force it in a different direction.
There's like, like, there's one way of destroying it and the other way of like fetishizing.
So we're going to write this Borges story and we're going to talk about the phases of rereading one's own work.
So like, you're going to go through a kind of self-congratulatory admiration phase,
but then you're going to go through a kind of developmental phase where it sends you off another outstripe.
So like, you know, so this character who only rereads his own work has different,
there are different epochs of his rereading of his work.
Yes.
Some of it's productive.
Some of it's just auto-effective and weird and compulsive.
Right.
We got a short story.
Someone write it up.
All right.
Well, okay.
You guys sold me.
I'm good.
You guys are right.
And I suck.
Well, I do.
I mean, look, I mean, that's where, I mean, it's, you know, it's true, but like, I have to learn to, I mean,
and I do think that that's true.
Like I got to get to that other, that other headspace in what I think in terms of the podcast.
And what's interesting to me as you talk about it was like, it makes me think what I was thinking
when you were just saying that Nathaniel was like, so I'm, I'm teaching again in the fall,
some fucking stupid thing or whatever.
But, uh, I think I'm going to do it differently.
Like I'm actually, you know how I normally teach.
It's like, I go in and I talk and I run it and maybe I'm not going to do that.
Maybe I'm going to go in and have a couple of questions and try to actually make it more
of a seminar or more of a discussion oriented thing.
The hard thing is I just get bored with the dumb things that people say and it pretty quickly
in, I mean, this is times that I've tried this before within 10 minutes into the conversation.
I'm like, all right, this is not working.
Like I'm just, I'm just going to explain to you because I'm way more interesting to myself
than you guys are to me.
Yeah.
Hey, it's understandable, you know, plus maybe, maybe it just takes a minute for, for,
cause you need like a couple students who are really engaged and to bounce off of them.
Some people are just, we've talked about it, like people are a little too nervous at first
or something and they don't want to really like put themselves out there in the class.
Yeah.
I found that at the beginning, at the beginning of my grad school tenure, I was not comfortable
speaking.
You didn't speak in class.
You didn't speak in class at all.
I, I didn't at all.
And I still, I mean, even towards the end, it's like kind of sporadic for me.
So it's like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Yeah.
No, fucking Nathaniel would talk incessantly.
It was irritating.
No, I'm kidding.
It wasn't irritating.
I was great.
It was great.
But, but it's also the case that we've sort of self-selected, right?
Like, and when you, someone signs up for your class, that's not self-selecting,
right?
Like they, they just picked a time slot or they picked a class that they needed or something.
I'm thinking in terms of a grad class, not undergrads.
I'm still just going to run it.
But, um, the problem with doing it with the grad class that was just, it has, for me, it
has a lot to do with sheer quantity is that I can develop really good seminar style classes
with my undergrad classes, especially my upper level undergrad classes.
If I, if, if I don't blow them away with the amount of the reading, like we're going
to, I'm going to spend straight up three weeks, you know, six sessions on just the waves, right?
Like we, when we did play those pharmacy, we did it over two weeks, you know, four, four
sessions on it.
And that, you know, even that was the dare, the dare die, I say on the dare die, I say,
right.
So we didn't do it.
Whereas like in a lot of grad classes and your, your class is no different than most
other grad classes.
It's like, because, because it's graduate training and this is supposed to be your life
and you know, there's so much stuff to deal with.
It's like, you've got, you know, this book and these three essays or these two books and
you know, say or something like that.
And, and, and there it's so hard to develop a, it's so hard to become comfortable talking
about that in that, in that space of time that you almost need to, what's more important
are the narratives and the structures that you're, you're, that you're being given by
your, by the professor, right.
That because like it's, because frankly, the class is really more about like a little mini
thesis that you're getting from, from the professor and less like when I teach my undergraduate
classes, like I'm not teaching you content here.
This isn't about you mastering the discipline in any kind of way.
This is me just like, you know, this is where we're using, you know, this artifact as something
to respond to thinking like a lot of what we're doing in this, in this class.
And you know, it's in, in, in my, this is the capstone theory class that I teach, you know,
the Misen theories about writing class.
And we read like five texts total.
Well, let me go.
We've got the Phaedrus, Plato's pharmacy, The Death of the Author.
What is an author?
The two short essays that we actually did in one day, the Wolff one and the Deleuze one.
And then, um, the way, that's it.
That's, that's seven texts.
Seven texts.
Two of them are six page short essays, right?
Bart is super short, but it's that space.
It's that pace.
So when you do, let me ask, when you do the lecturing, do you do that at the beginning
of the class or do you do that as it emerges or how do you do it?
I do it for the upper level class.
I've been, I haven't been lecturing every class period.
It kind of depends on what the, what we're, what we're teaching and where I feel like the
conversation is.
And I have them do forum posts too, um, to try to get, feel that out.
Um, but yeah, it's usually at the beginning of a class and usually up front a little bit
more like on, you know, I'm more likely to lecture on day one or day two than I am on
day three or four.
Although, you know, like if I'm doing four days on, on Plato's pharmacy, I probably, you
know, I probably did a lecture on day one and day three, maybe, you know, and then, you
know, and the lecture was only half of the class.
On the other days, how do you, do you come in with like a list of questions or do you,
I mean, how do you get into a discussion?
And I'm, I mean, specifically on something like Derrida, right?
Like, um, not, not on the waves where like I get that people can sort of read the way,
but I, but with something like Derrida, like Logic of Sense, I would imagine if I assign
something like this to teach, people are just going to read it and be like, I got, I got
nothing, right?
Like I, you know, so how do you, how do you generate, how does it start?
Right?
Like how do you get into it?
Yeah.
I mean, I get you.
So day one, you give a little bit of background and you say, this is where it comes from.
These are some of the big ideas.
This is what people talk about or whatever, whatever.
Um, and then how do you get into the text and the, the, the interaction with them on the
text?
I, well, the, because we've already read the Phaedrus, you know, a whole, I'm trying to make
links and trying to point to ways that, that Derrida is intersecting that text.
Um, what I'm trying to do is set up a lot of the dynamics and the questions that are available.
So I won't just articulate a question.
I'll like talk about a dynamic and then articulate it as a question to explore and not, right.
And the role of desire, what is the role of desire in this, in this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
And then I'll try to like animate, like, like, you know, for example, how,
how does the interplay between, you know, the, you know, that, the text that is the scroll,
you know, the, the, and the, the dynamic between Phaedrus and, and, and Socrates and how is
Lysias figured within this economy of desire or something like that, you know, like, um.
So how do, how do you deal with problems of what I would simply call understanding?
Meaning, uh, like, let's just take the first page of Plato's pharmacy where he talks about,
I mean, to me, that first page is fucking amazing, right?
Like it's, and everything's there, like adding a, adding a thread, uh, or subtracting a thread.
So, you know, to me, that's something that like, do you explain that to them?
Or is there a point where you say, do you guys understand?
Because I, the answer to this is certainly no.
Do you guys understand what he's saying in that?
Those last two paragraphs there where he talks about adding on and, uh, giving to read.
We spent the vast majority of day one on those first two pages.
Those first two pages.
And, and, you know, and I told them upfront, like, we're going to be spending a ton of time
on this.
They wrote about it in their forums.
They kind of came in and that's the thing.
And they've really latched a lot of the ones that are wanting to write on Derrida now or
have incorporated Derrida into their project.
Like that's, they've taped, they've really, they, they, like they've operationalized and
maybe not on all of its nuances, but they have like a decent operational, you know, familiarity
with the sense of like a text as being a fabric or a collection of webs and like the reading
as a kind of a decision, like a making a kind of cut and then their reconstitution of that
fabric along different lines.
And, and so like, you know, we have, I think what allows me to get into difficult texts that
are very difficult on their own is that, you know, it's because we went from the Phaedrus
for two straight up two weeks to The Pharmacy for like two weeks and then to questions
of like authorship, you know, for another two weeks with Foucault and Barthes that, you know,
they've, they're able to, there are a handful of dynamics and, and questions that stay stable
enough that allow them, that give them a framework for reading the difficult stuff.
So like on day two, for example, or day three or, you know, like on, on, after I've, like
on a day that they're all kind of dedicated to talking, but the ones that are totally dedicated
to talking, you know, like, you know, I'll have like five minutes at the beginning where
I'm trying to recap some of the dynamics that we talked about last class.
And then I'll always pull in a few people's forum posts to be like, you know, this person
was thinking about this.
And, you know, I thought that's really interesting in the way that it intersects this other person's
thinking on that.
And, you know, my, I, what I would really like to be able to do today is think about
how these two things, you know, how they intersect this third dynamic.
And we'll go back to the Phaedrus and that scene, remember that scene where blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And, you know, keep in mind what we were talking about with, you know, the reasons that, you
know, the pharmacon is left untranslated here and the sort of necessity of, you know, translating
in this kind of way.
I mean, I'm making shit up right now, but trying to create a framework for, for those, those
conversations.
And again, like they got out sometimes, but they, they work a decent amount.
Okay.
So what I'm going to do, I mean, I'm doing the grad class I'm doing, there was a screw up
cause I was, I thought I was doing the special topics one.
Remember I asked you guys about topics and, um, you're doing performativity.
Yeah.
So, um, although I'm sort of thinking of changing that cause, uh, um, the re I was, I thought
I was doing the topics one.
It turns out Byron was.
And so I call Byron and Byron's like, yeah, I'm doing new materialism.
And I'm like, well, he's, he's doing new materialism.
I don't want to do post-humanism the same semester.
That seems ridiculous.
So, but what I'm supposed to be doing is the, the seven 94, the, the rhetorical theory one.
And so I just defaulted.
I'm like, well, whatever I did last time, cause it needed to be up within an hour or something.
And that what I did a year ago or a year and a half ago was the performativity one, which
could work.
And that could be fine.
But I'm sort of thinking, maybe I'll just make it a Derrida class.
Like just a class on Derrida.
I mean, I, I don't know what would draw students more, um, performing performativity or Derrida.
I mean, it seems like they'd probably be sort of slightly, probably the same kind of crowd.
I'm guessing, um, for either one of them.
Um, but maybe I'll just like really, really, really, really reduce the reading load and not
have some big coverage version, but just have, cause I, I mean, I always try, I feel like
I'm pretty good compared to other folks.
Like I, when we're doing theory, I don't assign more than a hundred pages a week.
Like I, or I try to limit it to a hundred pages a week.
Um, so if you were rolling your eyes, like, eh, that's not what I recall.
Um, or, or do you think that the a hundred pages, cause I'm thinking now, like, maybe I
should just do 50 pages a week.
Like maybe I should cut that in half.
And if I, certainly if we're doing Derrida, like Signature Vent Context, if we're doing
performativity, Signature Vent Context is a week.
Right.
And then The Limited Inc Essay is another week.
So, I mean, those, those things for sure, I'm going to give those things week, How to Do
Things With Words, but is that too much?
Like Austin's How to Do Things With Words in a week?
Like, is that too much?
Should we do two weeks on Austin or three weeks?
You're doing, I mean, you, you only have the one day in the week, right?
One day a week.
Right.
Yeah.
I find probably Austin, the problem with Austin is that the, the best part of Austin is the
iterative approach where it's like, he's finds himself, you know, like backing up and reflecting
and that, that, you know, there's, there's, that would make me want to do, um, two weeks
on it.
But, um, on the other hand, there's just not as much to it.
There's not as much density there as well.
There's not.
Right.
So, I mean, I thought the pacing was fine of that class, but again, like the reading
load, like for me, I, I don't read everything equally, but that's because I latch onto the
stuff that I like, and then I really think hard about that stuff and, but I don't read
for like total, I mean, not like, I don't always read for total comprehension, but students
feel like they need to do that.
So you give them a hundred pages and they freak out and they feel like they need to fully
comprehend that whole hundred pages.
So for me, I didn't have a problem with it because I always just thought, well, I'll,
I'll, I'll fucking, you know, skim around and find the stuff I wanted.
Right.
In the, in the undergrad theory class, there's almost no discussion.
It is 100% like it's interactive lecture, but that's how I always am.
Like I'm lecturing and then people might, there might be an interjection and we go off
on a tangent, but it's basically, I'm telling them here are the things that you need to know,
not what do you make of this?
So maybe I'll just read, try redesigning that class.
And I mean, it is, it's, it's, you know, what you guys are saying, I'm taking it in terms
of an explicitly pedagogical register, but you're thinking of it in terms of, you know,
like the podcast and what function the podcast performs for listeners.
And I am very much stuck in, you know, this sort of like, well, this is a pro, you know,
at a certain point when we're doing it, we're doing whatever we're doing.
But then when I think of it, I think like, what's a product that other people are going
to want to listen to?
Meaning I take a totally different approach to thinking about it as a podcast that I do
and thinking about it as we're, as we're making it.
And maybe it's that difference or that chain, that, that alteration that is the thing that
maybe that's occurring to me now.
Like maybe I need to interrupt that and interrupt it, not just in the podcast, but also in my,
the way that I approach classroom stuff just to, you know, what the fuck?
I mean, I've been doing the same thing for 15 years, so why not try something else?
I found your classes engaging with your standard format, you know, so, but because they're
conversational, you're not like, you're not doing a ton of reading and it doesn't feel
like a, a lecture in the sense, like here are the main points that you need to take away.
And here's how we build off of those.
Your classes feel like this sometimes, you know, where you're just, you're talking through
stuff and maybe a couple of students like who are really into it, like we'll, we'll engage.
I mean, that's what I thought was appealing about your class.
So, uh, do you think people would be interested in a Derrida?
Like if I just do modern rhetorical theory, Derrida.
Yeah.
And we're just going to, and we're just read like three things or four things of Derrida's
Grammatology, limited ink, a couple of essays, and then some ethics of friendship, Marxism,
whatever.
I mean, that's a pretty common.
Yeah.
The difference essay.
Grad school model, right?
It's just like, this is the, I mean, I've even encountered grad school.
They're like, we're doing the Iliad.
Right.
And a handful of essays and responses to the Iliad.
But, you know, it's just basically that.
So I think focusing it on Derrida is, is not at all too ambitious for a grad class.
I mean, too selective for a grad class.
But for me, I mean, you know, I've, I've tried to be very selective in what each one of my
classes is trying to do.
Like it, and, and, and it's almost never, or at least the classes that I've enjoyed the
least are like, I'm trying to survey content.
And I've got like one class like that, right?
You know, so the, well, my basic rhetoric class has basically been, I am going to give
you tools for analyzing, rhetorical tools for analyzing texts and for sort of like using
as little like inventive invention machines for your own writing.
And the entire class is going to be organized around you writing an essay for a popular audience.
Like you're writing for the New Yorker, you're writing for the Walrus.
And we're going to spend the entire semester, like, you know, day one or like one week, we're
going to be talking theoretically about ethos.
And we're just going to try to get a handle at a theoretical level.
What is ethos?
And then the next week we're going to look at this article, this article from the Atlantic
and we're going to like, how does this article produce an ethos?
And then you're going to think, well, like, how, what are some of the tricks and tips that
I can use to produce my own ethos for this article that I'm going to be writing and focus
my entire semester on?
So that's that class.
But the other, I'm just choosing the two classes that I'm teaching right now.
The other, the upper level theory class is organized around one question.
What is writing?
And, you know, so, and, and obviously that's a really big, you know, generic question, but
it's something, it's a stabilizing ground where like, when you feel like you're kind of going
off the rails a little bit, it allows you to say, like, it allows you to return, it gives
you a touchstone to be able to return to.
And, you know, I think you can obviously see how Pater's, Plato's Pharmacy, the Bart Foucault
pieces and the waves, you know, are all like, let's, let's look at some, you know, they're
called the myths and thieves or myths about writing or myths and theories about writing.
It's like, let's look at the sort of the mythological function of the author, the mythological
function of the, you know, of communication as, you know, and, you know, those are sort
of like, you know, that feels like those are pretty simple points to make, but we joke
all the time how I, it feels like it took me X number of years of graduate school for
me to finally like figure that out.
So it doesn't seem crazy to me at all to make that recurring touchstone of a class and sort
of exploring it from a variety of different angles.
But so like, if you did the Derrida thing, you would have to ask yourself, like, what's,
what's the thing driving, like, are you trying to look at the way that Derrida's writing
thinking has evolved over, over, over the course of, of something, or you're like, look, what
are, you know, what's, let's try to understand difference and the sort of the variety of other
pseudonyms that sort of, you know, he uses for it, like iterability and citationality and
whatever.
The trace.
Yeah.
Let's just like, yeah, the trace, like, let's, let's just say like, look, we're going to read
four different texts or we're going to just kind of really try to get a, an intimate,
you know, familiarity, develop an intimate familiarity with this thing that he's working
through and provisionally thinking about.
In that sense, I feel like I should stick with the performativity thing because I feel like
that's the thinking of performativity is one that I feel like is more important to different
grad students who are not doing, you know, straight up theory work, you know, to me, and
I still believe that's the single most important concept and it's, and it's orbit of concepts,
the elocutionary and, uh, but, but, um, I think Butler's gender, gender version for sure.
And then Barad's sort of critique.
And Barad.
Um, so, I mean, maybe I would just do that.
Just do like Austin, Derrida, uh, uh, Butler, Barad.
And that's the whole, that would be the whole class, right?
Like just those four, but even those four, there's so much stuff to read.
So I didn't even have to reduce that.
So what, but one of the things, so what I could do is I could have our syllabus just be like
these four texts, right?
Like, I mean, how to do things with words, uh, signature vent context, limited ink, uh, yeah.
Gender trouble, post-human performativity.
Those are our texts, but under each of the weeks I could have like a ton of other stuff
that they could read then suggested readings.
Yeah.
These are the things that we're going to be talking about and animating the conversation.
And these are, these are our touchstones and we're like, how does performativity get thought
of and, and, and, you know, how is performativity performed over the course of these five texts?
And then that's what you should be able to come in and be ready to talk about.
And that's the question that you should be able to engage every single week.
And then all this other stuff is like, look, you've got your own projects going on.
You know, what we might sort of jump over here, jump over there.
You could also do, I mean, if, if you want to add anything new to the, to the syllabus,
the Nealon's book on biopower and pop music, you could do a little section of that,
maybe couple it with like a section of an essay from Foucault.
Cause by, I mean, power is also, is performativity as well.
So if you, if you want, if you want that in there, I mean, people might like the popular
music references or something with Nealon.
Well, if we release this, if we release this episode, we're like with the Deleuze cast,
it'll just be titled No Deleuze.
There's just simply no Deleuze in this episode.
Oh, come on.
He was mentioned a couple of times.
Okay.
We'll see you next time.